you've a need to promote [ __ ] [ __ ] my
new special my new comedy special
where's it at Amazon Prime great
when is it come out it's out sup just
came out about a month ago a month ago
what's it called it's called caramel
corn the Pug kick him in the kibble is
it really called that yeah yeah did the
whole special as a dog then our
specialized a dog is that true yeah Oh
caramel look it up look it up look you
have to look it up it's caramel corn the
pod our special I don't see if it's real
the force of nature keeps popping up
caramel caramel go to Amazon Prime and
type in caramel corn the pot yeah Wow do
you know it you you dressed up as a dog
in it I have a mask with a pug mask with
an articulating mouth that moved when I
spoke and so I did the whole set as a
dog no audience no there was 600 people
oh right oh wow yeah would you do it at
the Irvine improv oh I love that yeah I
love don't you love that room yeah
that's pretty good yeah yeah so you know
rosenbaum from that movie that you guys
did sorority girls sorority boy boys
music that you rosenbaum and somebody
Barry Watson Barry Watson it's a guy
from seventh heaven mmm they can go hey
bingo yeah but do you audition now or no
you don't like to need for things or I
don't a lot anymore cuz I just don't
like it but IIIi I'm more into not to
sound snooty but I like getting just
offers but if it's something I really
like I'll go out but I turned down
almost everything yeah
any same way I just and it's not it's
not because I have an attitude it's just
I I find there's a proliferation of a
lot of stuff out there now when I was
kind of coming up through the movie biz
there was there was just movies and
studios and now there's a
more and so a lot of stuff you go in and
you're excited and you realize nobody's
ever gonna see it or it's not gonna it's
not gonna have a big platform or so I
kind of you know I feel proud of the
work I've done in the movies I've done
and so I just want to do stuff that
meets that bar now but if it doesn't I
don't want to I don't want to do
something don't you want to play I I
feel you know like I'm on a show now no
one's ever recognized me from the show
and it's an ABC network sitcom do you
have the whole network thing yeah yeah
beep I no one's ever said I love you on
that but I thought you may love me for
other things but it is the new game
right there's a new game to be played
with all you mean in the industry right
and I and I want to play it yeah all
right
and what I was gonna say to you is is
that through this interview in my head I
literally thought you would be a really
great dad on a show like a really funny
weird dad on a show
imagine having a show about a kid and
then there's an another kid that's weird
and that's the dad Yeah right I mean I
could just see different scenarios with
you in it because you're a little older
now I'm old as well you know my point is
is that I just think that you know I
know I think I knew that about you cuz
you're the same as me I don't like to
read either I hate him I [ __ ] dread
it yeah but I do do it you know me and I
hate it but I do it yeah and sometimes I
get it you know I mean so hopefully you
know you'll find something yeah and you
know you know I'm at a really good place
where I've been blessed to have done
some really great projects for me and
and I think projects that have you know
reached other people and I really am at
the point where if I never acted in
anything again I'd be like great I had
I'm really happy with what I left behind
yeah now if something good came I would
I would love to do it but I really if if
nothing else happened I could go and
what AG what a blessed life I had you
know
self-actualization sweetheart I think
about what I know what you took so what
you said was so like impactful I just
needed a moment but then you just kind
of I stepped on yeah yeah so just let me
have that
okay you say it again
you said something about like if I
didn't I didn't act again right okay
I've had a I've had a lot of blessings
and I'm happy with what I've done
yeah I don't feel that anymore yeah it's
gone I think geez
anything you wouldn't want to promote
them except for this aside from that
special I would like to promote well I
would like to promote for I have a show
on Disney Junior animated series called
puppy dog panels I have seen it
thank you and I'd like to mention that
for if people have kids kids love it and
that brings them lots of joy and so
puppy dog put the cute and remember I
brought you to the living room I was
like sweetie this is Harlan Show can you
believe oh yeah yeah we're like we were
in shock or shocked by it yeah cuz II
sabelo was watching it yeah that's yours
right Wow your face anyway Harlan
Williams pop for yourself friend you did
great job friends